exactly six months after eleven people
were murdered at a synagogue in
Pittsburgh another deadly gun attack on
a Jewish place of worship those inside
were marking the end of Passover when a
gunman opened fire with an assault rifle
killing one woman and injuring three
others an off-duty Border Patrol agent
returned fire but the suspect wasn't hit
shortly afterwards he surrendered to
police as our officer was actually in
the freeway he clearly saw the suspect
his vehicle suspect pulled over jumped
out of his car with his hands up and was
immediately taken into custody by the
Sandy Police Department president Trump
commanded officers for apprehending the
suspect my deepest sympathies go to the
people that were affected the families
their loved ones by the obviously looks
right now based on my last conversations
looks like a hate crime hard to believe
hard to believe police say the suspect
had posted anti-semitic comments online
and he may be linked to another racist
attack in the area
John Ernest date of birth six 899 he's
19 years old and as far as we can tell
has had no prior contact with law
enforcement and it looks like he said
we're looking at the possibility of his
involvement in the mosque Burnie and
Escondido back a month ago we will get
through this our thoughts and prayers
will be with the families and those who
are investigating how whey will stay
strong and will always be a community
that cares for one another
politicians have United to condemn the
attack former Vice President Joe Biden
who's just joined the race for the White
House said we're in a battle for the
soul of this nation in woods Sky News
Washington